alors essence hockey pression ok j'ai
crise terminée
mais j'ai surpris à la con l'arrière
tout le monde ya toutes les amies même
je suis prête et félix
est-ce que ça va mieux je vais partir
partir
d'accord ou pas loin mais pour être
dépaysé avec tout ce matériel oui
j'accorde une grande importance au matos
étaient prêts là
super show faite à l'e3
les jours c'est joli si son budget
oui le mouvement fait tache en son
endroit où dormir mais profond du
terrasse vous voulez vient de loin avec
temps canoë es-tu là où bat le pouvoir
possible
et qui sait quand un témoin entendu
callas connard
elle met les femmes courant il faut
savoir le sentir la compagnie tout ça va
sonner supporter
merci à tous merci il fait beau et tu
continues
à un aventurier luneland sur montcuq
mais monsieur faut arrêter cac